buongiorno le cene incredibile di
vederli tutti insieme qua oggi parliamo
un po di design che la bestia un po
strana perché tutti pensano del design
sia scarabocchiare qualcosa
in realtà lo era una forma di arte
applicata però le cose stanno un po
cambiando anzi sono cambiate
radicalmente nel tempo
immagino che ognuno di voi almeno una
volta nella vita abbia avuto a che fare
con l'equazione tra energia massa spazio
tempo no è invece penso proprio di sì se
voi guardate il nostro amico alberto
l'equazione è uguale emmeciquadro tutti
noi capiamo subito che esiste un
equazione tra masse nel giro incredibile
einstein è stato una delle più grandi
menti del genere umano in assoluto e
oltre a essere uno scienziato come tutti
noi lo conosciamo stato anche un
designer che detta così sembra una
fesseria clamorosa però se guardiamo
alla definizione di design
ci rendiamo conto che lui ha guardato
oltre l'orizzonte dei suoi tempi lato
ultrà si è chiesto delle cose che gli
altri non si chiedevano è riuscito a
semplificare senza e spogliare del
contenuto qualcosa che andava ben oltre
l'orizzonte del descritto l'intero cosmo
4x4 ni molto eleganti perché noi
noi ci ricordiamo di questa però la
questione sta leggermente più complessa
interazione di campo e tutte queste cose
il problema è che noi tendenzialmente
ormai ci siamo abituati a dare per
scontato quasi tutto
se non li guardo adesso alcuni di voi
hanno queste piastrelle raccordate
cellulari ce l'abbiamo tutti appunto la
piastrella raccordata cosa cambia un
rettangolo con gli angoli smussati
io penso che dieci anni fa ben pochi di
noi sarebbe riusciti a concepire
qualcosa che non ha una tastiera
adesso non c'è un telefono che ce
l'abbia uno guarda strano dice come
ancora quei tastini riusciamo a
scambiarsi messaggi in tutto pianeta in
tempo reale a farci i fatti degli altri
e guai se non lo facciamo meno mezzo al
giorno no perché saranno silvia wow
siamo tagliati fuori dal contesto
in realtà se ci pensate
questo il risultato di centinaia di
designer studiosi e scienziati che sono
riusciti a trasformare una cosa molto
complessa come la tecnologia in qualcosa
di accessibile per tutti noi
einstein ha fatto lo stesso altre ha
trasformato il cosmo in quattro
equazioni
ora io non sono einstein sfortunatamente
per me è fatto molto molto meno però ho
imparato una cosa vivendo la sua mia
pelle che fosse il caso tv racconti
circa nove anni fa più o meno per tutta
una serie di fortunosi coincidenze mi
sono trovato a hong kong a lavorare per
la giochi preziosi ai tempi avevano già
una decisione che si occupava di peluche
e andava anche piuttosto bene
però io uscivo da 12 anni di design in
trudi e quindi si aspettavano
il salto di qualità va bene mi era stato
chiesto di creare qualcosa di diverso
un'altra ennesima serie di giocattoli
animaletti varie size e io dall'alto
della mia modestia quella volta risposi
no lo sono non lo faccio
no la cosa non è stata presa
particolarmente bene perché l'azienda
del genere il no non è ben accetto io
sapevo che quello che mi era stato
chiesto non probabilmente non sarebbe
funzionato problema è che non avevo
nessuna risposta in mano non sapevo che
cosa avrei dovuto disegnare
non avevo idea in realtà loro non
avevano peluche normali come quelli che
avevo disegnato fino a quei tempi
avevano tutta una serie di
prevalentemente cagnolini interattivi o
camminando si siedono dall'assetto
interagiscono gli fischi cammina crini
però per come la vivevo io sembravano un
po po freddini no giocattolo è pensato
soprattutto un peluche per essere
abbracciato questo è portato a letto
difficile che uno si porti a letto un
pezzo di plastica coperto di pelle e poi
pensavo ma i bambini no volta che gli
fai fare ti pollán olimpionico effetti
serie di altri segni di quella 50.000
volte batteria finisce e con lui con
quelle muore anche il giocattolo
il che non è una bella cosa immaginate
il vostro amichetto che muore
cominciando a pormi delle domande
marco e adesso cosa facciamo perché poi
il problema è sensibile un muro o botto
non è morbido come fa essere morbido
essere stato di plastica con tutti gli
ingranaggi dentro per forza di cose
visito non cominciamo bene
ogni piccolo pezzettino più tu assemblee
chiaramente costa e ogni in funzione
proporzionalmente significa il
consumatore finale deve spendere un
sacco di soldi e cosa gli fai fare
perché questi già facevano tutto cosa
vuoi che faccia ma poi c'erano dei
problemi di ordine produttivo più un
prodotto e complesso più la fabbrica che
lo deve produrre deve essere capace di
costruirlo e non è che in cina stiamo
parlando di gente che fa prodotti cinesi
che conosciamo tutti
quindi mi sono trovato la situazione
abbastanza delicata perché francamente
avevo tutti contro no era impossibile
nano nano non c'era via riuscita
apparentemente ho pensato ma
ma forse sono io mi sto facendo dei
problemi che non esistono sto dando per
scontato delle cose che scontate non
solo parliamo di anatomia di un
giocattolo e guarda me stesso sta in
piedi uno scheletro si non sono
propriamente tonico però insomma diciamo
che sono anche abbastanza rigidi non ho
però quando dormo solo su sfop ha chiuso
e poi pensato se un giocattolo deve
essere un amico cos'è un amico per noi
un amico non lo definiamo per cosa fa
ma per quello che è o anzi meglio per
quello che noi riteniamo lui sia noi
tutti abbiamo un'opinione nostra di noi
stessi
ma voi avete l'opinione di me per quello
che vi sto raccontando quindi ha pensato
tutto sommato se le azioni nel tempo
sono limitate
e costano forse tutto sommato è meglio
che mi ha giocato lontanamente e forse
tutto sommato gli occhi il mio
giocattolo sia emotivamente carico e dal
punto di vista interattivo emotivi
spoglio e voi vi chiederete quindi cosa
è disegnato un giocattolo che non fa un
tubo un giocattolo che non si muove
no il giocattolo che ho disegnato ai
tempi era un pony
si chiama tofi ed è stato in assoluto il
primo giocattolo della storia capace di
esprimere le proprie emozioni prima pony
di peluche interamente animato e morbido
ma mica ha fatto la magia non ho
semplicemente copiato me stesso qual è
l'articolazione più complessa che
abbiamo nel nostro corpo a particolare
il ginocchio è un po parti un po troppo
particolare è quella dell'anca
articolazione splende idea ci permette
di ruotare il nostro fema e come
vogliamo così come totti poteva muovere
la propria testolina essere morbida
nello stesso tempo è il sistema era
modulare per cui con le stesse robotti
che potevo creare altri personaggi e
topi in realtà non faceva niente solo
raccontava le sue emozioni attraverso
l'espressione del suo viso del
orecchiette e soprattutto è stato il
primo giocattolo della storia a prendere
paura quando dice posti come perché
doveva prendere paura perché tutti noi
prendiamo paura tutti noi siamo fragili
io sono super fragile immaginate a
parlare davanti a cento persone che non
conosco è propriamente simpatico eppure
mi rende un essere umano mi rende
fragile e dà la possibilità a un bambino
di prendersi cura di qualcuno che debole
perché noi lo facciamo spontaneamente fa
parte di noi fa parte della nostra
natura e quel giocattolo così
impossibile perché era impossibile fine
tre mesi dopo uno scarabocchio
notti insonni passate a cercare di
mettere insieme questa robotica era
fatto perché in realtà non c'è niente di
impossibile nulla ero io che mi stavo
ponendo dei dubbi non esistevano perché
io miro incancrenito pensare in modo
lineare per dare per scontate le cose
che è nata ascoltate non erano mi sono
trovato un po come abbondante quando si
è trovato a vedere dio e lui non non
riuscivo a quantificarlo era impossibile
no
il geometra che in quel caso
l'architetto cerca di misurare la
circonferenza del cerchio come fai una
isola circonferenza del cerchio se tutti
noi sappiamo che definita da pi greco
che un numero infinito ma poi più o meno
quantificare ma non ha senso un numerone
eppure tutti noi la conosciamo è un po
la soluzione sta in quello del cartiglio
di leonardo che ci dice che noi siamo
iscritti in un cerchio qui
eccoci qua siamo iscritti in un cerchio
il design ci definisce attraverso i
prodotti nostro telefono c'era un così
tutti uguali però il nostro telefono il
nostro per il contenuto che c'è
all'interno così come il mio giocato la
unico perché il contenuto del bambino
che lo possedeva e se vuoi 5
guardate a quel cartello vi rendete
conto che l'orizzonte del design non è
un orizzonte lo descriviamo noi sono gli
angoli
i vertici di quel quadrato che ci
definisce che sono parte di un toccano
una circonferenza che il nostro
orizzonte delle cose la cosa
straordinaria è che tutto si semplifica
l'essenza del discorso con e posso dirvi
come funzionata in realtà noi non
disegniamo mai niente per noi stessi
noi disegniamo o concepiamo cosa parlo
di disegno
in questi termini disegno industriale ma
si applica a qualsiasi modello di
business non disegniamo per noi ma
disegniamo per gli altri perché gli
altri siamo noi
qualsiasi cosa che funziona non è un
prodotto fatto per l'individuo ma è
fatto per tutti gli individui e
l'incredibile semplificazione che non
significa le spoliazione del contenuto è
la chiave di lettura per fare in modo
che il messaggio arrivi a tutti perché
questo perché noi siamo incredibilmente
complessi
ognuno di noi è diverso io ho le mie
esperienze mio bagaglio di cose che ho
fatte nel passato
voi avete il vostro ma la cosa
straordinaria che mi sono accorto è che
pur essendo dall'altra parte del mondo
le molle psicologiche che si muovono
sono le stesse per tutti
non cambia nulla quindi così come è
successo per einstein che tra sommato le
stelle in quattro numeri così come dante
che ha dovuto usare delle metafore per
descrivere dio perché come fai a
descrivere dir
la descritta incerti anche lui quindi il
processo disse mourinho
anch'io mi sono trovato a semplificare
per cerchi ea trovare la concentrata di
quello che noi siamo un sistema
apparentemente super complesso
eppure così incredibilmente semplice e
delicato